twilight princess HD is a ten-year-old
game that's been given a facelift which
is to say it wraps sharp new textures
around its polygons everything else is
old the audio synthesized doing things
like climbing ladders can be a bit of a
fuss and the gameplay overall lacks the
convenience of modern action RPGs but
overall there's actually something
quaint and wonderful about the old
fashioned way that Twilight Princess
plays in the ten years since it was
first released on the Gamecube and we
most adventure games have become sort of
obsessed with being a slick and
streamlined as possible games have
become absolutely terrified that you'll
get lost so you have all these gimmicks
to keep you on track things like the
mission checklist on your pip-boy in
fallout 4 or the sat-nav system that
guides you through the witcher 3
Twilight Princess doesn't have any of
that it's old-school insofar as it
leaves you to your own devices hands
unhealth
sometimes it's straight up doesn't tell
you where to go next
it forces you to explore to investigate
ask around play curious what a red joy
it is to be lost in hyrule searching
across its fields and mountains and
towns and rivers in pursuit of something
how old this approaches but how new it
feels there's a serendipitous bliss to
the details you make throughout your
main quest you'll stumble into dark
alleyways secret catacombs niche
boutiques a village straight out of a
spaghetti western and a magnificent
stone bridge about a quarter mile across
not since Ocarina of Time has a Zelda
game offered a world of this scale and
activity with so much confidence and
it's the residents of this world who
make every journey seem worthwhile
Twilight Princess sees nearly every
character as an opportunity to inject
more personality and charisma into its
world the gorons are aggressive and
territorial locals of Death Mountain the
Canon operator is a downtrodden clown
with bulbus pitiful eyes the Yeti up in
the wintry north has an adorably
gigantic bum and speaks in all cow
the hyrulean town beggar promises good
fortune if you keep giving him rupees
and just as a word of warning I've spent
about 700 bucks on the guy so far and I
haven't got anything back then there's
Zant the Magnificent mad sidekick of
Ganondorf who plays as chief antagonist
for the majority of the story I just
couldn't take my eyes off him Sant is
unbelievably sinister and weird in an
enigmatic sort of way and that can be
more appropriate than Twilight Princess
this game is dark it's brutal as creepy
it features an alternate version of
Hyrule that is engulfed in shadow it's
wonderfully bleak the lighting is the
Mucky yellow of a cigarette stain while
squares of ash whizzed through the air
as though Nintendo had made a snow globe
from an ashtray
as link enters this Twilight Realm for
the first time he transforms into wolf
link later he can freely switch between
beast and human and this is clearly
Twilight Princess his big spin on the
old Zelda formula it's no disaster but
it doesn't quite work as well as it
needed to wolf Link's main attack is a
straightforward lunge or a tentatively a
charge spin which gives a battles of
pedestrian pace and a narrow scope of
strategy akame this is not fortunately
you can play as human link for most of
the 40-hour adventure and each of the
game's 9 dungeons will test links
arsenal of moves and weapons to their
very limits the dungeons it has to be
said are simply outstanding what amazes
me so much about them is how even the
most elaborate challenge is the kind
that tests your memory and lateral
thinking are built around a simple
question how do I spin that fan
how do I smashed that ice how do I reach
that platform in search of the answer
you will flood reams of water walk
upside down across cave ceilings lined
with quartz fashion a giant swing from a
sextet of placated baboons and carry a
cannibal across the icy halls of a
mountain peak mansion this is
quintessential Nintendo intricate
answers beautifully folded into a
straightforward question
unfortunately the dungeons and the game
as a whole is just far too easy don't be
too amazed if you never die once
throughout your entire quest there's a
new hero mode which makes things much
trickier but not really in a satisfying
way it's not as though the AI has
improved you just take more damage
Twyla princess HD is unmistakeably a
product of its time when it's released
in 2006 it wasn't just one thing it was
it was many things it was a love letter
to hardcore Zelda fans made during
anxious times for Nintendo it was
developed for to console simultaneously
it was the Gamecube last hurrah and it
was a weed launch title it was a
defining test for motion controls which
by the way have been stripped out so
because it was all these things and more
Twilight Princess has always had a sort
of warped identity perhaps now ten years
later it can finally be remembered how
it ought to be as a dark and brilliant
showpiece of a treasured series